they just can't get my nose right well
flynn rider that may be because you were
never actually supposed to be entangled
at least the original story with a
roster
of hundreds and hundreds of characters
it might be hard to imagine that there
are disney characters that never made
the big screen
but it's true these characters could
have drastically changed the plots of a
lot of our favorite disney classics
who could have guessed that tangle's
flynn rider was almost entirely replaced
or that ariel was actually supposed to
be a dolphin friend
definitely not us if you're ready to
head into the depths of the disney
archives and find out all about the
characters that could have been
well oh buckle up please don't freak out
in 2020
imagining rapunzel without her flynn
rider can be borderline
painful for some disney fans but what
they might not realize is it was pretty
close to becoming a reality
instead of the dashing brooding but
complicated criminal
disney originally planned on having a
character named bastian to be the main
love interest
while bastian was a thief he was
orphaned as a child
and despised the life he was living in
order to survive
it was planned that bastian would visit
rapunzel's tower where he would sweep
her off her feet and convince her to
explore the outside world
along with this blonde anti-hero came
two other scrapped characters
his sidekicks crowley and griffel
together
the three were working on a plan to
dethrone the king and queen rapunzel's
parents
even more shocking is that bastion's
burly appearance was actually later
recycled for another huge
disney character he was used to create
frozen's kristoff
as the story progressed they decided
that flynn's character would be a better
match but his design actually wasn't
changed until the very last second
imagine a world where both flynn rider
didn't exist and kristoff looked
completely different
yeah we don't want it it's just not
meant to be
moana's fierceness and maui's rapping
definitely brought a whole new dynamic
to the world of disney but
this film originally had an entirely
different storyline
that's because disney deleted a total of
nine different
characters from this film that's right
9. and they were all meant to be moana's
older brothers
reportedly an alternate storyline
included moana going on an adventure to
save her brothers
in fact the creators gave us the inside
scoop on a scene that included moana
out sailing her brothers in a race but
the brothers were scrapped after the
creators decided to have moana's ability
to sail be questioned
we lost the brothers and we wanted to
make her less proficient when she was
sailing
how exactly do you think a movie with
moana's brothers would have gone
would heihei the rooster still be
involved so many questions
actually had a mom that's right disney
sketched out
and developed a whole character named
xena that was meant to play aladdin's
late mother
the aladdin creators have admitted that
getting rid of xena entirely was
never part of their original plan in
fact getting rid of her was emotional
for a lot of people in the production
office
mostly because it meant that the song
proud of your boy would have to be
scrapped
eventually it was decided no matter how
beautiful the song
getting rid of the character altogether
would be the best option for the
storyline
lucky for us the song has since been
released to the public
reportedly the backstory goes that zena
entrusts aladdin with a rug to sell but
he gets into trouble and loses the rug
entirely
his mother plans to sell her engagement
ring in order to make ends meet
he returns the engagement ring back in
the middle of the night and vows to
finally make her proud of him
ooh brb currently drowning in our tears
after all i am your biggest fan
with this next deleted character the
incredibles may have finally met their
match
zarek was the original villain targeting
the incredible family in the film
but as the story progressed the creators
decided that syndrome would be better
fitting to the tale that they were
trying to spin
but he was just too good to pass up
zaryk still got his moment to shine
in the incredibles comic book series
where he comes face to face with
elastigirl
while zarek definitely seems like a
threat we're pretty sure the incredibles
would have been able to take him down
free zerek wasn't the only character
scrapped from the incredibles films
anyone who's watched the first movie
knows frozone's iconic line
honey where's my super suit where's my
super suit
not gonna lie always wanted to say that
on youtube anyway
and while we never get to see the wife
he's talking to
she's become a fan favorite that's why
for the second film she was almost a
reality
sketches for honey were made and
everything but in the end the creators
decided to keep her appearance up to the
viewer's imagination
her appearance in the film wouldn't have
exactly changed the film's storyline but
we bet the audience would have loved a
cameo
no one's saying do this now when i said
that
simba almost had a brother-in-law no
we're not kidding
me too a character that was sketched out
and made it pretty far into the creative
process
was supposed to be nala's younger
brother me too existed when the film was
still called king of the jungle
creator linda wolverton says nala has a
big brother that i included so she could
protect him from scar
in the lion king laserdisc he was
described as a tag along little brother
who was always getting into trouble
the character was eventually scrapped
but his sketches are still out there
you got a friend in me
woody and buzz were this close to not
having a friend in jessie
senorita cactus came very close to
completing the trio in toy story 2.
the cactus toy was supposed to take on
jessie's role
as the story progressed she then became
an accomplice to stinky pete
eventually though the pixar creators
decided to scrap the character
altogether but they couldn't go without
leaving an easter egg in the fourth film
she makes a cameo in the tiki frenzy
pinball machine scene
this character would have definitely
changed everything about the franchise
bullseye wouldn't even exist
counting 10 9.
shakes the rattle is another forgotten
character in the toy story series
this character made it into the movie
but their scene was ultimately deleted
after the content got a little too dark
for the g-rated films
in the scene the gang is watching as sid
terrorizes yet another toy
and then just as buzz is about to
interfere another toy rattle interrupts
and recounts the scary time
shakes was thrown by sid into the
neighboring window all they could hear
were screams
they never saw him again yeah yeah okay
that's definitely dark
we hope shakes is okay yes yes
splen you what beauty and the beast is a
tale as old as time
but with these next three deleted
characters the story originally looked
quite a bit different
first up is the music box just like the
curse turned lumiere and cogsworth into
animated objects
the music box was originally supposed to
be part of belle's companions
the idea was that she would speak in
song instead of words
it's been rumored that her deletion had
to do with being outshined by everyone's
favorite
chip while she never got any lines the
creators
still featured her in the background of
some shots during the film
did you see that it's a girl
i know it's a girl the next beauty and
the beast's character would have altered
belle's character
completely in early drafts this future
princess had a younger sister
named clarice in a deleted opening scene
clary's can be seen running to their
aunt who comes to visit
however the creators decided to strip
belle of any other family members to
really show the audience how lonely she
truly was
thanks for the angst disney papa what
are we going to do
we'll think of something beauty and the
beast viewers almost got a peek at
belle's mother as well
what's up with disney deleting all their
motherly figures funnily enough
this deleted scene was also supposed to
involve a music box
as a gift on her 17th birthday belle's
mother passed
down her music box to belle although the
scene was scrapped
little hints of her mom can be seen
sprinkled across the film
she's mentioned in the film's song no
matter what where her father compares
her to her late mother you are your
mother's daughter and in her cottage a
portrait of belle and her mom reading
can be seen hanging on the wall
hmm we wonder what her name would have
been
[Music]
thinking about ariel as anything but her
eccentric self goes against everything
we know when it comes to the little
mermaid but
originally this red-haired mermaid was
lacking her spunk
another character a dolphin named beaker
was meant to be ariel's best friend
and was the one supposed to carry all of
her excitement the little mermaid's
director john musker opened up about the
character and said
we got a note in the early development
of the script that we had too many
characters
so we ended up eliminating that dolphin
character and giving some of his
personality to ariel
she became as energetic as the dolphin
was and aren't we glad for that
oh look at me wasted away to practically
nothing
the little mermaid viewers were also
supposed to get a pre-warning of
ursula's evilness
before ariel could even meet her in a
deleted scene
a mermaid named harold traveled to
ursula and begged it to have strength
that would impress the other mermaids
harold quickly realized that he had been
tricked when the water lilies ursula
requested in return
weren't actually in season he was turned
into a polyp
his character was meant to really show
the sea witch's ruthlessness so that
the audience would be terrified when
ariel paid her a visit
or there's the march here
in that direction you might think that
the cheshire cat from alice in
wonderland was a strange character but
wait until you hear about the puppy
alice was meant to meet this oversized
dog before the mad hatter and the march
hare
the cheshire cat was actually going to
be the one to save her from the puppy by
scaring it away
[Music]
big hero 6 was an action-packed movie
even without these next deleted
characters but we can't imagine how
wild it would have been for hiro if
these villains were also involved
the fujitas were the most notorious
female criminals in san fransokyo
and were part of yama's plan to send
hiro and his gang to another dimension
but the creator decided that the trio
wasn't needed after yama became more of
comedic relief than an actual villain
check this out butler
chef theme song guy
before kuzco was his cool slick self
the emperor's new groove had a
completely different character
cuzco's fiancee nina nina was planned
during the early stages of development
so early that kuzco's name was still
written down as manko
she was meant to despise the spoil kuzco
for their loveless betrothal
there was even a duet written for the
two of them called one day she'll love
me
it's actually kind of a jam
you've heard of dopey dog sleepy and
sneezy but have you heard of deafy
it's been reported that over 50 dwarves
in snow white were brainstormed before
they settled on their favorite seven
deffy happened to be one of them he made
it so far in the editing process that he
even got his own drawing next to doc
supposedly deffy and grumpy were meant
to absolutely loathe each other
honestly their bickering probably would
have been hilarious
[Music]
this scrapped character from the
pocahontas film has a pretty sad
backstory
fans of this movie know how important
mikko and flit were to pocahontas
but before the creation of those
wildlife friends she was meant to have a
friend
in red feather the turkey unfortunately
the voice actor john candy
passed away while the film was in
production although most of his lines
were already recorded
the film was completely reworked to fit
a more mature audience
what would the cinderella films be
without gus gus
and the rest of cinderella's mice
friends definitely not as adorable
while they were always planned to be
featured in the film two more companions
were originally meant to be included
clarissa the turtle and jabber the crow
who were friends with her dog bruno
they were eventually cut after it was
decided that there were just too many
characters
these almost characters definitely would
have added
an entirely different vibe to some of
our favorite disney films
but as much as it would have been cool
to see aladdin's mother or
senorita cactus in toy's story we still
love our classic characters just the way
they are
everything happens for a reason right
buzz lightyear you are not worried are
you
what was the most shocking character
reveal for you do you think that the
disney creators should have kept any of
them
let us know in the comment section below
don't forget to tap the subscribe button
and give these disney characters a big
thumbs up if you want to see more videos
just like this one
from the things have a magical day